[MUSIC PLAYING]
IRENE STEVES: About two years
ago, I started at Riskified,
an e-commerce fraud-
prevention company
based in Tel Aviv, Israel.
Previously I'd worked with
ecological and environmental
scientist data.
I'd worked with a lot of
different kinds of files,
Shapefiles, XML, CSVs of course,
sometimes thousands at a time.
But I hadn't really
gotten the chance
to work so much with databases.
So I was really excited
to enter a world
where there were millions of
orders coming in each day,
there were teams dedicated
to setting up ETLs
to process that incoming
data and to get it neat
and tidy to databases for me.
And all I had to do
is query that data
into R and start playing.
And I was excited because
I had R under my belt.
And R was super multitool.
It seemed to be able
to do almost anything.
I used it to create
slides and websites.
I'd used it for querying
APIs and even building APIs.
It did a lot for
what was supposedly
just this statistical tool.
SQL on the other hand
was a little bit more
like a screwdriver.
It's a perfectly
fine tool, but it
seems to be only really
good at one thing, which
is to query databases.
As I was going to
Riskified, in my mind
was a little bit of
this feeling of why
bother to learn SQL if I can
just use R for everything.
And one reason that I
was fairly confident
is because I knew about
this package called
dbplyr, which is an extension
of dplyr that runs on databases.
So instead of running something
on a data frame in your R
session, you're actually running
it on a table in a database,
but it feels like it's
just a data frame.
And what it's doing is it's
taking your tidyverse code,
translating it into SQL,
sending it off to the database,
bringing it back,
and then giving you
this tibble output
like you're used to
as if everything all
happened locally.
And so if we look
at how this works,
let's just take a
simple R example
where I have now mtcars table
in this database, I take some
variable, miles per gallon,
round it, create
this new variable,
and then I select two other
variables, this rounded miles
per gallon and then horsepower.
If I look at the translation,
it also looks fairly good.
It looks somewhat
similar to the R code.
I'm rounding it.
I get the horsepower
from mtcars the table.
If I were to have
written this out by hand,
I probably wouldn't
write in the backticks.
But otherwise, it
looks almost the same.
And sometimes
using dbplyr really
saves you a lot of tedious work.
For example, if I want all
columns except for horsepower,
I can use this simple
expression in dplyr,
and then it generates
the SQL code
where I literally have to
write out every single column
except for horsepower.
If I want to now take
the maximum across all
of the different
columns, I can also
do it very easily in dbplyr.
It's just one line of code.
And then it's able to generate
this really long and very
repetitive query for me.
It's not a hard query to write,
but it does take some effort,
and it is very repetitive.
But the thing is,
over time you also
realize that what you're used
to doing in just regular dplyr
isn't always going to work when
you're connected to a database.
For example, if I
now want to look
at the number of NAs or nulls
across every single column,
I can use this one
liner in R. If I
try to do the same on a table,
will say no such column dot x.
It's angry at me
because I'm trying
to use an anonymous
function, and it
doesn't know how to translate
the anonymous function.
So what I have
to do is I have
to fix this set of commands.
I have to break it up into
the individual steps, which
is is.na first and then the
sum, and now it will work.
Well, now it will work
for some databases.
And this is where it becomes
complicated a little bit.
On the one hand dbplyr saves
you the mental load of learning
SQL, this whole new language.
On the other hand, you
start to realize that you're
working with databases.
It does a lot of
the translations
to dialects for
you, but you have
to know what is specific
to your database.
In some databases, for example,
is.na becomes a Boolean.
In other databases,
is.na becomes an integer.
And depending on
what you're using,
you might have to convert
it into an integer
in order to sum it up because
it can't sum up Booleans.
And so you have to make
sure to still juggle
that information in your
mind as you're using dplyr.
So it's you are using
something you're used to,
but you can't use exactly in
the way that you normally would.
And so over time
I did really start
to appreciate SQL,
the screwdriver,
because even they
have their moments.
And sometimes it is
easier to just switch over
to a different
language rather than
to try to juggle how regular
dplyr is different from dbplyr
code on this specific database.
And so for example, if I
take what I had from before,
I switch off the ending,
now I have a group_by
and summarize instead.
If I were to write
this out by hand,
it's also fairly
simple SQL query.
The ordering is a
little bit different,
but otherwise it has
all the same components.
If I now take the machine
translation of this,
it looks a little
bit scary at first.
It's going to run just fine.
It's just as efficient.
It's not going to
have any problems.
But you can see that
it's not as readable.
It's harder to distinguish
what here is really important,
what is just extra code that
is used to generate this--
to automatically
generate this query.
And so at some point, once
you have to hand SQL code off
to someone else, or if you need
to really optimize for speed,
and you need to input some of
these little database tricks
that you know about, you
have to dig into the SQL.
There's just no way around it.
And for me, it's kind of
like using Google Translate.
I live in Israel.
I did not grow up
speaking Hebrew.
I learned the alphabet
just a few years ago.
And I can get around
with just Google Translate.
I can survive.
But you also really quickly
realize that it doesn't--
you can't express yourself
exactly in the way
that you want to.
You lose out on a lot of
the nuances of the language.
And sometimes you
even have to alter
the way you input your
English sentence in order
for the translation to come
out OK on the other side.
Speaking of language, that's
one other really amazing thing
about SQL.
It's kind of this lingua franca
among the technical folks
in a company.
Of course the database
administrators
are familiar with it.
But also business analysts, data
scientists, software developers,
everyone has at least
that core level of SQL
So if you need to communicate
some actions you want
to do to data, this
is a really good way
to communicate
that through code.
And so with time
I realized really
that R and SQL belong
in the same toolkit.
And you can survive on
just one or the other,
but over time it's
really nice to be
able to use both
very well, especially
if you're in this intersection
of using R and databases.
The nice thing is
if you know one,
it's fairly easy to
become bilingual.
If you look at just the
main verbs, for example,
in each of the
two languages, you
see there's a lot of overlap.
select is SELECT,
group_by is GROUP BY.
There are some things
you have to learn,
you have to realize filter,
now WHERE or HAVING in SQL.
arrange is ORDER BY,
and so on and so forth.
So there is a little bit of
translation you have to do,
but it's not too big of a leap.
And the other thing is
if you're used to R,
then you write things out in
the order that they happen.
So let's say I have a table,
I filter by some condition.
OK, now I group by
some column and get
a summarized aggregate column.
And then I filter by
that column, for example,
and then I can arrange by something.
If I were to write this out
in SQL, I would have to--
I would start with the table,
the condition, group by.
Now, the select or the
summarize jumps all the way up
to the top.
HAVING is at the bottom again,
ORDER BY is also at the bottom.
And so you have to remember that
the ordering is a little bit
different.
You don't necessarily
write things in the order
that you would do them.
But other than that--
but it's something that you
get used to fairly quickly.
And if you're like me and you
spend a lot of time in RStudio,
the nice thing is there
are a lot of SQL things
you can do from within
that familiar environment
of RStudio, and especially
with the newer versions of IDE.
For example, if you
open up a SQL file,
you have your nice color
syntax highlighting,
so you can see what the verbs
are, what the table names are.
What I didn't realize
for the longest time
is there's this
line at the top that
says exclamation Preview
with some stuff after that.
This is where you can
actually set connection.
So if you set connection
to the database,
you can get the SQL preview pane
where you can preview that SQL
query within RStudio.
This took me a
while to figure out,
but it's a really nice feature.
RMarkdown is this kind
of magical document
where you can mix all kinds
of different languages,
and R and SQL is no exception.
You'll start probably with some
kind of YAML header like usual.
You might have an R set-up
chunk where you have packages,
the database
connection, maybe you'll
set up a table like
I did here, and then
you can have your SQL query.
And if you have this
inline mood enabled,
you can actually see those
previews within RMarkdown
And work with both R
and SQL interactively
within this one document.
And finally, you can navigate
through your database
from within R. You can see
what databases you have,
schemas, tables,
columns within tables,
all within that
RStudio interface.
And so I've talked a lot
about all these cool things
about R and SQL together.
But what does that
look like in real life?
I wish I knew more
about what people
are doing in the wider world,
out in the wild, so to speak.
But I can only really speak to
my experience and experience
of my colleagues at Riskified.
On a regular day,
I'm often switching
between a SQL IDE and RStudio.
I did just talk
about all these SQL
things you can do with
RStudio, but some are still not
quite that mature.
And so I really like
using the SQL IDE
for all of the extra
autoformatting,
highlighted code and
field suggestions
so I don't have to remember
those long table names just
from memory.
One other thing is that
it's really easy to stop
bad queries in a dedicated IDE.
Sometimes RStudio
get stuck, and I
press on that red button
for ages, and in the end
I have to just force quit my
RStudio and just start over.
On the RStudio side, there
are a lot of nice R features
obviously,
visualizations, reporting
being able to mix languages
in the same document
as we mentioned earlier.
But I think maybe
most importantly,
you have this ability to
organize your analysis project,
and on top of that
have version control.
That means you have
your SQL files,
your data files, your
R file, maybe RMarkdown
files all together in one space.
It's a project that you can
now easily give to someone else
and have them work on it
and have everything worked.
And on top of that everything
is version controlled
so you can connect directly
to GitHub and have it
all set there as well.
And so speaking of
project structure,
if you were to take a walk
through the GitHub repositories
at Riskified, you would
often encounter some kind
of folder structure
like this where
you have SQL files where
you're reading in relevant data
doing some initial
data processing,
getting that initial sample
population ready for analysis.
Then you have your
R files where you
do that all the complex steps,
the stats, visualizations,
et cetera.
Sometimes you're bringing extra
information from the database
in between with smaller queries.
And then finally, you
have this RMarkdown report
where you share your results and
conclusions with stakeholders.
And this is where
both of those pieces
really come together into
this one final product.
And because we're using R and
SQL so much within Riskified,
we actually have a
dedicated package
to handle those
database connections
and also just add little
helpers that help us
with our day-to-day flow.
For example, we keep
all configurations
within this package.
Anything that's
not too sensitive,
like host name, port, et cetera,
we just stick into the package.
If we need to update it, we just
update it in that one place.
And as long as people
reinstall the package,
it gets updated across
all the computers.
The other thing is that
we basically just use
one database, at least
among the analytical teams,
and so, unless you explicitly
provide a database connection,
we assume we know what you want.
And so that's built into our
very own get_query function.
There was one point
recently where we actually
had to migrate from one
database to another.
It was a bit of a
slog, but one thing
that did help smooth
it over a little bit
was this option we added to
switch between the old database
or the new database.
You just had to do it once
at the beginning of your R
session, and it would last
for all of your get queries.
So you didn't have to go in and
out to start changing your code
to specify the
database connection
for every single
query in your code.
One small thing that we do a lot
also is caching query results.
The first time you ask
the database directly,
the second time it will
store the results--
it will have stored the
result in some temporary file,
it's cached, ready for
reading, and unless you
force it to connect
to the database again,
you have a much quicker
response the second time around.
And that saves on a lot of
time as you're iterating
through your analysis.
And finally, we also have other
little helpers like access
to pipelines for bringing
large amounts of data
from R to the database
or the other way around.
Sometimes insert statements
just don't cut it.
And you need for
us what is easier
is to dump the data
into some Cloud storage
and then bring it directly
into the database or going
the other way around.
And so to conclude, R and SQL,
they both have their strengths.
R is great for
summarization across columns
especially in selecting
specific columns,
translations to
multiple dialects
if you're working with
several databases.
SQL on the other
hand, is great for--
like is really
needed when you need
to optimize for
speed or readability
because you're handing
it off to another team
to review that code.
And there's still
a lot to learn.
I'm sure I'm still on this
journey of learning how
to use R and SQL well together.
But I would love to
also hear from you.
Is your story similar,
different from mine?
My contact details are here.
And thank you so much
for listening today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]